there's a point where like new yorkers  get upset and everything just devolves  and to suck my dick i've seen two guys  give a fight it was a dude who's  homeless another dude kind of homeless i  think he was trying to like rob the  other homeless dude he's like yo get the  [ __ ] away from me i'm trying to sleep  they started talking [ __ ] and then my  dicks were just flying bro and it was so  entertaining i see this you know i'm  gonna sleep on the ground and i'm gonna  go to your mother's house so she could  suck the ground off my dick your mother  sucked my dick  your mother you won't kiss my dick  i might take someone up on that if they  say that just to prove a point suck my  dick okay okay  bring it out suck my big man joey  chestnut yo suck my dick all right then  what is that suck my dick  done you won you won